from the great Hans Kim
everybody thank
you thank you
guys I recently went to a strip club in
Atlanta or as I like to call it a black
box
theater
and my girlfriend got mad at me cuz I
followed all the strippers on
Instagram she doesn't like it when I
follow Instagram models she makes me
unfollow them which I think is the wrong
move because now I don't get to watch
them grow old and
[Laughter]
ugly they stay young and fresh in my
mind
[Laughter]
forever unlike her
hey if I'm supposed to call midgets
little people then what am I supposed to
call
Mexicans all right thank
you wow another new minute from Hans Kim
everybody absolutely doing it again
Redban and I both very impressed at your
unfollow Instagram joke thank you Tony I
maybe should have saved that one for
later but uh you know uh I'm glad that I
did it you're talking about your
upcoming Arena Battle Battle Yes Rick
Diaz against Rick Diaz but no I'm glad
that I did it got it out in my system my
girlfriend will watch it one week from
now um and it should it should be
fine does she get mad at you for all the
stuff you say on here she I blocked kill
Tony on her YouTube uh did you really
yeah it doesn't show up up anymore wow
and you think she doesn't have a way of
going and finding it I don't think she
wants to go out of her way to be
sad very interesting but she knew you
before she met you she knew what she was
getting into she was attracted to you
from this show yes and now she can't
handle it yeah you know like Patrice
O'Neal said the Fisher you get the fish
and then the fish is like why did why do
you have a fishing pole wait what what
no I think Patrice O'Neal probably said
it a little better than
that my goodness way to misquote one of
the
great all right should have stayed
alive
whoa
yikes wow so let's talk about this uh
Atlanta strip club a little bit um what
happened there did you get a lap dance
it was totally made up story just to do
some racism wow look at that just to do
some racism everybody not not just to do
some racist jokes he's being very honest
just to do some
racism not to do racial jokes not to do
jokes to do
racism I love it this is the hansim
we've grown to know and love yes truly
racist because he can get away with it
yes I mean I'm not racist I just enjoy
it a little too much
but like if you if you're attracted to
children but you don't [__] children
you're not a
pedophile you
know this is another there's a lot of
[__] a lot of tick tock Clips coming
out of this set
tonight holy
[__] wow did George Carlin once say that
what what great comedian
what great comedians Legacy are you
tarnishing
now oh my God this is incredible Hans
absolutely
amazing uh what do you guys think about
Hans Kim any words of uh wisdom from uh
steo or Adrian any any take can can you
explain the racist joke I just didn't
get it
uh the Black Box I mean a box is a slang
term for [__] right and then and uh a
black box theater is like a a theatrical
venue like uh you know it's like a place
where you watch Shakespeare
into that it's where people perform when
they start standup if they're not
already worldwide famous steo
uh if they're not a giant movie star and
you start an art form you perform in a
blackbox theater
so that was a great joke thank
you that is true
that is true I showed my work I'm an
Asian I do
math I love
it I absolutely love it Adrian any
thoughts on Hans Kim I like that you
figured out a way to think about [__]
kids without [__] kids thank you you
really you really are
Asian it is true it is true we all look
like kids over there that's true
what did you just say we all what we all
look like children over there so oh okay
all right yes and also here yeah
everywhere we go want to get into it
amazing Hans Kim you did it again you
got the show started you're a legend not
an easy job to do and you do it every
[__] week Hans Kim everybody there he
[Applause]
goes all right I'm going to pull another
name to Wrangle while this person